foreign
do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad arshad Muhammad arshad has
helped develop all of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course definitely
recommend this course
to access the free life-changing
training now
when I saw this video it amazed me so
much and they showed me how amazing and
there is no other way that Islam is from
Allah look at this guy he's a Trader and
look at what he is weighing just to be
just when he is doing transaction with
the opposite person watch this for
yourself I saw your
brother's Channel check out on sisters
it really really amazed me inshallah
foreign
[Music]
brothers and sisters the person that is
buying from him wouldn't even care about
the weight of that paper but this shows
us something so profound and powerful
and there's a Hadith about this in an
Ayah which I want to mention to you guys
please listen carefully the fact that he
is weighing the paper which weighs four
grams which is eight Pence the one who's
buying wouldn't care but the fact that
the seller is conscious of it which he
doesn't he will not even be blamed for
it because it's a paper it's a given
that when you buy something you know the
cost of the paper and the packaging is
already in that pricing anyways the fact
that he's weighing it shows me I wonder
how this man weighs in front of Allah
him as a person what is his weight the
fact that he thinks like this and he
goes to the Hadith for the prophet is
and ask him about what is Islam what is
Iman and what is isan and the person
mentions each of the categories but when
it comes to essan which is the top up he
said it is as if even though he cannot
see Allah he knows that Allah can see
him something along those lines yeah
this is what the Hadith was in a
nutshell referring to that when you
reach that Pinnacle that everything that
you do the eyes that you look with the
steps that you take the hand everything
that you do you are conscious of it and
you are aware and this is exactly like
describing the Skype and that you pray
as if you are seeing Allah and that if
you do not see Allah you know that he
sees you and he is the Austin of all
hearing and this is exactly what the
Hadith is about and guess what Allah
gives a warning how many subhanallah
people cheat in trade look what Allah
says
Allah says woe to the curtailers who
when they measure something to receive
from people they take it in full and
when they measure our way something to
give it to them give it less than Jew do
they not think that they have to be
raised up on a great day the day when
all the people will stand before the
Lord of the worlds brothers and sisters
this man embodied this Ayah fearing his
Lord and abstaining from cheating people
and he's not even cheating what he's
doing some people might see this Petty
brothers and sisters who may Allah make
us among those that are as conscious as
this man is that he will stand in front
of his Lord and his last statement when
he says that many people don't do that
he said they will answer to Allah and
maybe Allah might not bring the question
to this unless they're doing it
intentionally but it just shows that
he's more concerned about himself rather
than who's doing what I found it amazing
and hope you guys did this one inshallah
and till next time
and wallahi amazed
make us conscious of Allah
to this level